SOFTWARE ENGINEERS:
By now, I think we’ve established that software
engineers at FAANG companies are paid a boat
load of money.
This is usually anywhere between $175,000
per year to as much as $1.82 million per year.
While it’s extraordinarily difficult to
get to level 7 or 8 and earn the 7 figure
salaries, it’s relatively possible to get
to level 5 or 6 if you make the correct education
and careers choices and are willing to grind
out leetcode.
But, all of this comes with one caveat, you
have to go into software engineering.
From an objective perspective, this choice
seems like a no brainer, but not everyone
is good at software engineering, and even
if they are, they don’t necessarily want
to surf stackoverflow all day.
They’d much rather talk with customers and
colleagues, set business goals, and drive
forward the company.
Fortunately, while software engineers get
the highest salaries, there are several roles
at these companies that pay nearly as much
with no coding experience.
So, here’s the top 3 highest paying FAANG
jobs that don’t require coding.
PRODUCT MANAGERS:
Starting off with one of the broadest jobs
offered at FAANG, we have product managers.
Product managers are responsible for setting
the goals and vision of a given product and
coordinating the right people.
For example, if you were the product manager
of Instagram, your first goal would be to
define the needs of Instagram users.
For Instagram, this would probably be hours
of mindless entertainment along with social
validation.
The second step would be to create different
pathways in which your product can achieve
these goals.
One pathway might be to leverage photos while
another would be to leverage short form video.
Once you’ve got a couple of strong plans,
your job would be to convince senior leadership
that they should actually put resources behind
these plans and make them a reality.
If all goes well, you’ll have to work with
technical people to make sure that your vision
is actually executed correctly.
In the end, you’re performance will be evaluated
based on how well you achieved the needs of
your customers and stakeholders.
For example, how much did your idea increase
user engagement or how much did it increase
user satisfaction.
As you can see, there’s nothing that’s
technically difficult about this role, but
that’s also makes the job so difficult.
You’re often working with abstract concepts
and visions to produce quantifiable results.
On the brightside, while the title has the
word manager in it, you wont have any direct
reports unless you’re at an extremely senior
level.
This means that you can be hired into this
role straight out of college as an L3 product
manager.
And most of the people at this level are indeed
fresh college grads.
You definitely wont be working on something
as influential as Instagram or YouTube at
that level, but you may get to work on certain
subproducts of these systems.
For example, you may be in charge of Instagram’s
newsfeed or YouTube’s like button.
In terms of career trajectory, you have the
potential to reach 7 figures as a product
director, so there’s plenty of room to grow.
Also, most C suite executives were product
managers at one point in their careers including
Sundar Pichai.
So, you’re if you’re aiming for the moon,
this would be the track for you.
But, we should note that this is one of the
hardest careers to break into simply because
its so abstract and broad.
Virtually anyone can apply to this role and
meet the minimum qualifications, but it’s
extremely difficult to actually get an interview
and then convince the interviewer that you’re
the right choice.
Also, a lot of the products that you work
on will be experimental meaning that they’ll
be the first to get cut during a recession.
But, if you’re looking for a sort of entrepreneurial
leadership role, this would be the way to
go.
PROGRAM MANAGERS:
Moving onto a strongly related but starkly
different role, we have program managers.
Again, while the title has the word “manager”
it it, you probably wont be managing people
unless you’re L7 or beyond.
Instead, you’re role would be to manage
programs.
Your primary job as a program manager would
be the execute the vision of the product manager.
If the product manager was the CEO of a product,
you would essentially be the COO.
You would need to ensure that products are
delivered on time and within the budget.
For example, if the product manager wants
a search feature that can scale to 100 million
users, it will be your job to make sure that
the backend systems can keep up in a cost
effective manner.
This generally means working with software
engineers and solutions architects to create
robust scalable programs.
Basically, you would be responsible for bringing
together all of the details to make the product
managers vision a reality.
There are two main types of program managers
which are just program managers and technical
program managers.
If you’re looking into this role, I think
you definitely want to go the technical program
manager or TPM route.
Not only does the technical route pay substantially
more, but it’s much easier to score one
of these roles if you do indeed have the technical
knowhow.
One option for TPMs is to become a software
engineering TPM, but there are plenty of TPM
roles that don’t require any software engineering
skills.
Instead, they require technical knowledge
of cloud systems, databases, networks, enterprise
solutions like SAP, Oracle, Salesforce and
so on.
While it does take time to learn these disciplines,
you often become irreplaceable within an organization.
During a market downturn, it’s easy for
companies to slash products and thus slash
product managers and regular program managers.
But, it’s way more difficult to cut a technical
program manager whos responsible for Google
Cloud or essential internal software like
SAP S4 Hana.
So, being a technical program manager gives
you solid mix of having technical skills that
are hard to replace but also not having to
do technical stuff all day.
If you chose the regular program manager route
on the other hand, you’d be doing essentially
the same thing, except you likely wont be
dealing with tech products.
Instead, you’ll probably be dealing with
the supply chain, marketing or UI.
For example, if you were a supply chain program
manager at Apple, you may be responsible for
ensuring that enough iPhones make their way
to retail locations in the southern part of
the US.
Similarly, if you were a UI program manager,
you may be responsible for testing various
UI features and delivering the most effective
set of features.
You should keep in mind though that if you’re
targeting one of these broader roles though,
you’ll likely be facing a lot more competition
simply because more people will meet the requirements.
This is yet another reason to go down the
technical route, but in the end, it’s up
to you.
SOLUTIONS ARCHITECT:
Moving onto the next role, we have my personal
favorite which is solutions architect.
Unlike program manager and product manager
roles that appeal a broad range of people,
solutions architect roles are usually extremely
specific.
These roles are very technical meaning that
you can’t BS your way into one of these
roles, but that’s also the beauty of these
roles.
You’ll only be competing with people who
also know the technical stuff, but what exactly
does a solutions architect do?
Well, one way to think about it is that they’re
basically the software engineers of none coding
tasks.
For example, if you need to code an algorithm,
you would contact a software engineer, but
if you need to deploy that algorithm onto
the cloud at scale, you would contact a cloud
solutions architect.
That’s definitely an oversimplication of
the role, and there are some solutions architects
that need to know coding.
But in general, solutions architects handle
all of the technological tasks that don’t
involve coding.
This includes things such as migrations, deployments,
database management, network management, cloud
infrastructure, and IT security.
Usually, you’ll choose one sector to be
an expert in.
For example, you can be an expert in cloud
solutions and know the ins and outs of AWS,
GCP, and Azure.
Or you can be an expert in enterprise solutions
and know everything about Oracle, SAP, and
Salesforce.
Given the technical nature of the role, job
security is usually on par with software engineers
if not even more.
This is especially true if you specialize
in something like cyber security.
Just because the job requires a bunch of technical
knowledge doesn’t mean that you’ll be
doing technical stuff all day though.
Much of the job has to do with conveying technical
information to non technical people.
For instance, if you’re an internal solutions
architect, you would likely need to work with
a bunch of internal technical program managers
and provide them with the best backend solutions
for a given product.
If you’re an external solutions architect,
you’ll work with enterprise customers and
help these customers implement your company’s
solutions to the best extent.
If you were a solutions architect at AWS for
example, your job might to be keep Netflix
happy in terms of the backend.
In terms of career trajectory, solutions architects
don’t quite make it into 7 figures, but
that’s simply because there’s not as many
levels.
In terms of the compensation at each level
though, you basically get the same compensation
as a TPM.
For example, an L7 solutions architect at
Google makes $535 while an L7 TPM at Google
makes $527.
Also, if you’re a star solutions architect,
you’ll have an easy time switching to senior
TPM roles.
For example, a reasonable switch may be to
go from being an L7 enterprise architect to
being the director of enterprise resource
planning which basically an L8 TPM role.
From there, you can become a managing director,
VP, Senior VP and so on and so forth.
So, in the end, if you’re willing to do
technical stuff but don’t want necessarily
want to code, solutions architect is definitely
the way to go.
ALTERNATIVES:
As you’ve probably noticed by now, this
video was mainly focused at tech roles that
don’t require coding, but these companies
also hire a bunch of non tech roles as well.
For example, they need accountants, data scientists,
product designers, business analysts, recruiters,
and so on.
And these companies pay well for all of these
roles.
For example, an L6 Google recruiter earns
a whopping $335,000.
With that being said though, in the end, these
companies are tech companies meaning that
the people who are the most valuable and most
influential will be tech workers.
This primarily consists of software engineers
and the people who work directly around software
engineers like product managers, program managers,
and solutions architects.
So, if you want to play an integral role at
these companies but not have to code, these
three choices are by far the best options.
If you’re more of a business person and
want to create overarching goals and visions
and not really deal with the technical stuff,
you might want to look into product management.
If you’re comfortable dealing with some
technical stuff but still wanna mainly focus
on the business side of things, you probably
want to look into program management.
And finally, if you’re super comfortable
with technical stuff, but you just don’t
wanna do coding specifically, you’re best
bet would be to become a solutions architect.
All of these roles are in high demand not
just inside FAANG but across the entire job
market.
In the modern age, virtually every company
needs IT solutions and all of these roles
are essential in delivering said IT solutions.
So, even if you aren’t able to crack into
FAANG directly with one of these career paths,
it’s more than likely that you’ll be able
to make it into a background company like
Cisco or Oracle.
And from there, if you’re truly a star performer,
it’s just a matter of time until you make
it into a FAANG company if that’s your goal
of course.
Which role sounds most appealing to you?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’d like to be paid
a FAANG salary.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.